the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants studios i can't say thank
you enough for your support if you look
this community continues to grow and
grow my goal was to hit 2 000
subscribers and we have absolutely done
that i can't thank you enough for that
uh look you're getting the honeydew now
a day early ad-free no additional cost
this shit's five bucks a month you guys
know that and if you like what you see
and you're in for the year sign up for
it because you'll save and you'll get
over a month of free episodes all right
um if you or someone you know has that
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com we'll
vet em we're ahead right now we're
reaching out telling people hey stay in
touch so keep checking your emails the
stories are coming in they're getting
just
absolutely out there and today will be
no exception i promise you that uh i'm
very excited to introduce this lady
right here um please welcome to the
honeydew with y'all y'all
miss randy kiosky everybody welcome to
the honeydew with y'all randy
you all right hey thanks for having me
all right you're welcome girl you're
welcome
uh we've been chit-chatting before we
started and now we're gonna start you've
got quite um
i would say a wild historic
historic past that we're gonna get into
but before we do um please tell us right
now where where are you
i'm in detroit michigan detroit michigan
all right and how old are you
33 33 okay and what do you do for a
living
i am a freelance hair stylist and a
dominatrix
all right but you weren't always a
freelance hair stylist in dominatrix you
have a very interesting past that i
would love uh to hear about and i'm very
excited that you're willing to share
this because
it's a criminal past and um
crime always fascinates me so please
um i know [ __ ] really pops off for you
around age 11. but can you tell us
what is going on the first 10 years of
your life that leads you to what you're
about to tell us
so um i was born to
a polish mother and a native american
father so there was a lot of alcoholism
and abuse when i was growing up my
biological dad beat the living [ __ ] out
of my mom so
my life was hell and hectic before i was
even born really
um my biological dad was an organized
crime and it was never talked about what
are you allowed to say what kind of
organized crime your dad was in
yeah so he was affiliated with the
cartels and also with the russian mafia
oh also
god yeah he's d
and you said cartels there was an s on
the end of those cartels i know i asked
you off camera before you you said i
plead to fifth your honor so
your honor i get it
uh so
it was something that was never talked
about but it was known he claimed he
owned two oil change um stations but he
also had a fleet of porsches
he also had a ferrari he also had a huge
multi-million dollar house
and
my mom had tried to get child support
from him and he was paying like twenty
dollars a month come on child support
and where where was he do you have any
assets i see he was all
he was in detroit mostly but then he
moved to a smaller town okay
but so he kept all his money off the
books and claimed uh i'm broke
so i don't have to pay you anything more
than 20 [ __ ] dollars a month but let
me let me drive by you in my ferrari
right exactly picking me up in porsches
and things like that and ferraris yeah
but um he was putting things in other
people's names
so
um my mom and i lived in section 8
housing
over by
russia and rosemary in detroit which is
on the east side which is the absolute
worst neighborhood in all of detroit i
was the only
white girl in that whole neighborhood so
you know my mom was working being a
single mom and i was forced to be out in
the streets and kind of keep myself
occupied
and i didn't have a lot of
support a lot of guidance i was really
left to my own devices so did you have
other siblings on the road did you have
other siblings
my stuff got into the picture yeah my
stepdad got into the picture when i was
10 and then had my little sister when i
was 10 almost 11. but up until then it's
just you and mom
it's just me and mom got it okay
and you're in this world rough ass
neighborhood you've got no male
influence
really in your life at all
and you're
i'm sure mom's single mom out there
doing what she's got to do work and
everything else and you're just
you getting what raised by the streets
raised by wolves
wolves
yeah okay so 10 years old you you're
still in the same place you're still in
that same neighborhood and house and
everything section eight yep yep i lived
in that comes in
yeah so um my stepdad didn't actually
make enough money
for us to move out of that neighborhood
but we moved out of section 8 but just
into more of like a low income housing
so we were still in like the same
neighborhood we just weren't in the
actual projects if that makes sense yes
it does
so how did your mom and this guy meet
they met at a bar okay true love true
love that's where love is found you know
until the light comes on
you gotta get out of there before that
light comes off
oh when that light came on she was
pregnant so
that's not that fast
okay so now at age 11
what happens
so at age 11 um i had already for a
couple of years been seeing the the guys
in the neighborhood that had you know
typical story the nice cars the
bankrolls of cash you know and and
things like that so
i had gotten approached because they
asked if i wanted to join so i said yes
they said you know gave me promises of
making money and that we wouldn't have
to struggle anymore and i could get my
mom food stamps and things like that so
i got jumped into the gang at age 11 by
eight grown men now the same female
jumped me no eight grown men grown we
talked about 18 20s
yep how many of them
eight
eight sorry eight
not one female
not one female and they just what is
jumping in for you what did they do they
just beat the [ __ ] out of you like
yeah
so it's they they basically beat the
[ __ ] out of you for
anywhere from 30 seconds to a minute and
it's just hay makers and uppercuts and
you're technically not supposed to fight
back
but i wasn't having that i was swinging
on them back so when when that all got
done
they were like wow you know you got
heart like nobody ever swings back so
that kind of set a precedence for
my personality who i was what i wouldn't
i wouldn't take so
that started that's how that started how
many other 11 year olds are in the gang
at this time
i was the only female
at that time that was around my age but
there
there was like like my my cousin was in
it
and
his brother got into it and they were 11
and 12. so what when they're beating
your ass are they kicking you in the
ribs and [ __ ] when you're on the ground
like they're just going for it they no
mercy even though you're an 11 year old
girl no mercy no
kicking me in the face kicking me in the
head kicking me in the ribs did you have
any broken bones or anything when you
were done
nope damn all right yeah so now you're
in this gang at age 11 and
you say in the email you're the is this
right you're the only white girl
ever in the history of this entire
what's the name of the gang
the gangster disciples gangster
disciples and you're the only white girl
that's ever been
a member
of this gang
i'm not the only
white female that's ever been a member
there's a lot of different sectors
but the only
white female that got to the ranking
that i got to that moved like i moved
and got the respect that i got because
um
to be
an actual gangster disciple not just
starting your own clique you have to be
recognized from the top from like larry
hoover who started it all in chicago
wait
really that's legit this one guy has to
recognize you
well the people that he is because he's
in he's in prison in colorado
with like the
like in a maximum security prison he
can't get mail anymore or anything
so it's who he assigned underneath him
at the top they have to recognize your
gang as being an actual legit sector
to be able to be a real gangster to
sniper disciple or else you're just a
click you know okay
and you
move through the rankings what do you
have to do as you move up what what do
you start as what do you start doing at
age 11 what are you doing for this
so at age 11 i started out as a
messenger and i was responsible for
taking messages from because we they
didn't want to use phones and things
like that or notes so
i'm already paralleling this to the wire
in my head yeah like the hoppers and the
young kids running around just yelling
5-0 that's like the base level [ __ ]
did you ever watch the wire
no i haven't okay yeah
so um you're literally running messages
you're taking messages to people because
they don't want to communicate on the
phone
but they're not writing anything down
either so it's i take a message from one
person verbally and give it to another
person verbally and i'm also standing on
the corner being like a lookout for
people that are doing like hand to hands
you know
so that's how i started out it's called
like a foot soldier
okay a foot soldier got it now uh what
happens next where do you you go up the
ranks to what
well i went up the ranks from that to um
elite foot soldier which is basically
i'm responsible for doing the hand to
hands i'm responsible for you know when
cars pull up i i hand them the drugs and
things like that
and i only had to do that for
about a year before i moved ranks and
then
go ahead i was going to say at that age
you're now touching product and
everything are you are you using do you
start using drugs at that age an early
age like that or does that [ __ ] scare
you and you just stay straight
um i
started to smoke weed at like 11 or 12.
and i started drinking about 11 or 12
too but i wasn't doing any hard drugs at
that time okay
so now you're moving up through the
ranks of this gang
and what do you wait i want to see
because you
yeah you gotta what was your final one
what was your high rank
i was a general which in some sectors is
also called a governor i mean i oversaw
multiple
sectors for you were in charge
of multiple sectors and now that's the
only that's the ranking that no other
white females ever achieved right
right no other white female god damn
girl you made history with them
yeah and i think there's only maybe
one or two other females that have ever
even gotten to that rank look i know
we're talking about gangship but
let's talk about sexism for a second
like how i feel like you probably had to
double prove yourself every time because
they were like [ __ ] this we're not
listening to some chick tell us what to
[ __ ] do so you're already in a hole i
imagine that you gotta you gotta work
this much harder just to get to zero and
then even harder to show
you're worth it you can do your job
right you probably work harder than any
dude in that gang has ever worked to get
to the ranking you got to it was my
guess
absolutely um
a lot of it was
me not snitching on people
me taking hits for the gang me doing
putting work in for the gang
you know i was
you know i started so young
so
i was basically just completely devoted
to them for pretty much my whole life
and i had you know when i would i would
get in trouble or i would be questioned
about something or you know detained on
something
i never said anything where a lot of
other people would give clues or you
know would start crying about [ __ ] and i
was just never like that i was just
never like that i was wired
yeah just stone cold
so are you dating two at that eight
you're that's your whole pr prime teen
years are you dating guys within the
gang or do you have just one dude and
you just date him only or do you not or
do you date outside the gang
so um i dated one guy inside the gang
named bobby
but
they ended up cutting him up and setting
him on fire
the rival gang did so that didn't last
long so then i stopped dating guys
after that it didn't last long like you
guys had
like you have relationship issues
i don't think that was the problem for
bobby you know
[Laughter]
what do you mean they kind of they did
it kill them or did they just do it and
they [ __ ] them up charred them up and
scarred them up oh no they killed him
they cut his body up and then set him on
fire wait whoa you mean they they
severed his limbs is what you're saying
they didn't just stab them and carve
them up they chopped them into pieces oh
my god yeah
and then set him on fire and nobody
could find him for a really long time
and he was your boyfriend at the time
yeah oh my what is that what are you are
you not freaking the [ __ ] out about that
no not really because i kind of think
that everything happens for a reason and
um
i was just so focused and drilled into
what i needed to do that
i
when someone has nothing to lose that's
the scariest person in the world you're
right about it i feel i didn't have
anything i didn't have anything to lose
you know what were they going to take
for me my life i didn't give a [ __ ]
about that so take my life that doesn't
[ __ ] scare me so never once are you
like all right i'm i'm in over my head i
need to get the [ __ ] out you were like
now we're all in and going to the top of
this thing
yeah that kind of [ __ ] just drove me
harder so i'm like oh you want to [ __ ]
with my people you want to [ __ ] with my
[ __ ] okay you know everybody's got
family everybody's got somebody that
they care about you know and everybody's
got fear and i'm gonna figure out what
that [ __ ] fear is
and then i'm gonna play on that that's
how i felt about it so what did you do
about that
um
no comment
[Music]
yeah i gotta say that you are the
prettiest criminal i've ever met in my
[ __ ] life i gotta tell you you
are a ride-or-die i could tell i can
tell you ain't giving [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
you know
my looks
helped me a lot i learned from a young
age that it's crazy what a man will do
with just the thoughts the whisper
[ __ ] you know what i mean and i figured
that out like i don't know every woman
tells me that like unfortunately
you figure out very early on that pretty
pretty does this for me yeah
yeah yeah so i also
talk
i could turn off and on
like my hood talk
so that got me far too because if i
would get questions about things you
know what i mean from police and things
like that i would say look at me do i
look like i do that [ __ ] and they you
know that would get me out of a lot of
stuff but it would also help me
manipulate rival gang members and things
like that with the thought of them being
able to [ __ ] me and all of that kind of
stuff where
then you know my biggest thing for about
two years was going to
rival gangs trap houses and robbing them
with you know 10 guys with me of their
drugs and their money because they're
not going to call the [ __ ] cops and
say hey somebody just came in here and
took all our drugs and money and i
learned that really young so i'm like
[ __ ] that
we're gonna go and take them we have
bigger numbers than them and they're our
competition so we're gonna take what
they have you know
and you would be in charge of that
yeah for about two years that was my
biggest thing was robbing rival gang's
trap houses walk me through the um
closest like
come to death on something like that you
ever get into a shootout
um yeah a few times i've been shot four
times i've been shot at
more more than 12. god there was there
was you've been shot four times
oh yeah bro can you show any bullet
holes on camera any scars
yeah can you see that one
yeah i see that one
yeah
i didn't even is that your collarbone
like right through there
yeah i didn't even go to the hospital
for that one because
we just pulled it out
you just popped that [ __ ] out
yeah with a knife
[Laughter]
where else have you been shot on your
body where on your body um i've been
shot all up and down
all up and down my legs
was it from the same incident like a
shootout are these different everyone's
a different time
yeah one time i was shot three times and
the other time i was shot one time
you just said one time i was shot three
times
i mean it's my life
[Music]
okay hold on let's i want to hear about
these tell me the story of how you got
shot three times
so we were on
um 96 and we i was with one of my
friends at the time and he was driving i
was in the passenger seat we were up in
an escalade
and
he saw some people that he had problems
with on the highway
so he shot over me he rolled down my
window shot over me from the driver's
seat
yeah wait he's driving puts down your
power window over here and starts
popping
driving across you into that car
yeah so he's driving shooting like this
at the car
i i had my seat leaned back but we
didn't know that that car that we had
hit or he had hit
was being followed by another car so
when that car swerved off the side of
the road the car that was following them
started following us and he had already
emptied his clip
so
i know they got us and you didn't have a
gun on you
no comment
so they shot you up then
yeah you know what um if i wouldn't have
been in an suv
it would have actually hit all along my
rib cage in my intestines instead of my
legs so thank god they were in a car and
i was in an suv because you're sitting
up higher yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ]
all right so now you're a general
and tell me what's the day-to-day for
you as a general and and how old are you
as a general
again um by the time i was a general i
was
20 21 21 okay and what's your day today
you said you said here in your in your
email i'm sorry you said um
you said um we got to talk about
overdosing um hit by a car
where was the one you were the main plug
tell me about that moving work from
chicago to milwaukee and detroit what do
you mean by that
so um
has pretty strict gun laws
and
indiana has really lean drug drug uh
laws so
it was easy to get guns from indiana
and sell them in illinois
so
we would do a lot of that and also we
would move like um
like drugs and things like that that
would come up through to chicago and
move that you know through gary indiana
up to detroit and sometimes go up to
milwaukee wisconsin okay
so that's what the work was
and you're the main connect if i want to
get it in that area that's you
if you want to if you want to buy you
know weight yeah but if you're looking
to just buy like a gram of coke like i'm
not your girl if you want to buy a
couple of kilos i'm your girl but that's
about it
that's about it okay
yeah
um tell me the scariest [ __ ] you had to
do
ever in that gang what's the scariest
[ __ ] you had to do
like probably the scariest [ __ ] i ever
had to do
was
uh
go into someone's house
and kidnap them that was probably the
scariest thing i ever had
somebody
like grown people
a grown man yeah
you had to go to walk me through that
so allegedly what happened was i love
the way you talk i love the way you talk
allegedly what happened was in this
fairy tale
that
they had a back door that they would
leave unlocked
and because the wife would come home she
worked like the third shift so she would
come home late
so i had already been scoping out that
whole place you know what i mean and
when he was asleep all the lights went
out
i just went in the back door
and
allegedly
and
he was asleep so it was just kind of a
nudge with a gun
wake up don't make any [ __ ] noise you
know
your kids are here you need to come with
me and i had other people with me i
wasn't by myself allegedly
and then you take this person allegedly
out of his home and allegedly take him
where
i can't recall
and what what
that [ __ ]
that air pop was like i don't even want
to be in this [ __ ]
don't want to be implicated
um
look i know i've been doing stand-up for
20 [ __ ] some years and
still right before i got on stage my
heart races in like a good way i imagine
your heart i don't care what you're
doing are you not like just full of
[ __ ] adrenaline and some fear too
does fear propel you forward or
or did you just not register that
um there's always a fear of getting
caught
and what about killed what about shot
back
that never thing i told you
i mean it would enter my head but when
you have somebody that has nothing to
lose they don't care you know that was
just like part that was collateral
damage you know and what is your mom
does your mom know the extent to how
deep you are in this gang and all that
like how are you keeping this somehow
from her
so i'm keeping this from her because i
had moved to chicago when i was 18.
so i was you know five hours away from
her
but she would say things when i was like
you know 11 12 13.
like
i you know your little sister is here i
don't want anybody driving through you
know her her bedroom is in the front if
they shoot this house they're gonna kill
her
and then they ended up moving to the
middle of nowhere
like it i mean fields around them
because they were so scared about what
could have happened to the house but
they ended up moving
but nothing ever happened to them no one
no attempts ever on your family
no i had some threats about [ __ ] like
that but
um
those threats were
deaded
pretty quick
okay
tell me about um the first time you went
to jail what did you get pinched for
[ __ ] the first time i went to jail i
actually went to juvie and i was 13 and
i spent a year in juvie a year
yeah and do you know everybody in there
though or at least a lot of people
because 11 you're already in the gang
and it's a couple years now so it's not
you're not walking into like an a
complete
unknown
place
i mean i there were about 40 of us or
something like that in there and i i
knew two people but there were a lot of
people in there from like uh like
suburbs and things like that okay
yeah you're a different white girl from
the suburb white girls
oh yeah i know no i don't [ __ ] with this
i don't [ __ ] discover
you are not a suburb white girl no
i bet you sold a lot of drugs to some
suburb white chicks though that's where
they all come from at least in baltimore
they all come from the county down in
the city to get their drugs the police
will sit there and if you're white they
will stop you because the only reason
you're in that neighborhood as a white
person is for drugs that's it you know
yeah that's definitely how it was in
a little bit in detroit but it was
definitely like that in chicago i mean
the police would see you
you know and they would be like what are
you doing here you have no business
being on this side of town or in this
neighborhood and you know
so yeah so in your email you also say
you overdosed a couple times what um
when did you start using like heavy [ __ ]
and when what did you uh what did you
overdose on
so i
because of all the pain you know like um
from
being
shot so many times and things like that
you know like my body was really hurting
and so i started to use opiates to kind
of like heal the pain
and then the opiates started to feel
just really good i liked everything that
the opiates
made me feel and everything that they
didn't make me feel at the same time if
that makes sense it does yeah so yeah i
went down that rabbit hole
really bad you know i overdosed the
first time when i was
24 and then again when i was 27 and then
again when i was 31
what's the all on opiates
all on opiates you never went to heroin
like straight heroin no
no that's what i was doing with straight
heroin oh okay that's an opiate all
right i thought you weren't snorting or
shooting
um i did a little bit of both but it was
mainly snorting okay
and you overdosed and what happens who
who got you to the hospital
i'm not a hundred percent sure on the
first two times but the last time when i
was 31
uh that's just two years ago didn't you
you told me you're 33 right
yeah i was two um almost three years ago
yeah so the guy i was living with
found me with like my mouth foaming and
things like that and called an ambulance
and the ambulance took me there and i
had to be put on life support again oh
again you had to go on before
yeah i had to go on before
when um
i had overdosed the the other time
jesus christ
so how are you now
are you clean oh i'm good i've yeah i've
been clean ever since that incident
happened
all right good stay clean
forever all right so now
going from clean let's talk about dirty
a little bit
um you see you say here in your email
that you also ran a members only sex
club in chicago for and you capitalize
years on there how many years
five almost six years okay and you say
think eyes wide shut with no masks lots
of drugs and bdsm it was amazing in all
caps
tell me about tell me about how you get
into that
so when i was in the gang um i noticed
that a lot of girls were being pimped
out by other gang members and that
really bothered me
so i kind of took over that aspect by
the way i got to ask you that never
happened to you you never no never
nope because you were all i was like
that wasn't gonna [ __ ] happen to me
yeah no that wasn't i didn't get hoed
into the gang if you get hoed into the
gang where you get a train run on you
then that's usually what ends up
happening to you because nobody has any
[ __ ] respect wait so they'll have a
girl that'll [ __ ] the entire gang
everybody every guy yeah i mean don't
she'll [ __ ] all the high-ranking members
which can be anywhere from 10 to 15 guys
no way all at the same time
[Music]
i mean yeah one after another and they
only got so many holes yeah
and then
you're
but but then you're
all you are then is just like a [ __ ] toy
for the gang is that what you're saying
like you you don't grow up from that
you're just a sex toy yeah you can't
yeah if you get hoed in you can't that's
all you are okay all right yeah
yeah so um i had noticed that these
girls that
were
kind of in that position and these gangs
were making this money for these guys
that didn't give a [ __ ] about them so i
was like i'll take over that sector you
know what i mean like i got that i'm a
female i can understand that i'll make
you know you guys can take off the top
we'll still make a lot of money but we
can make even more money if i take this
over because i had really good
connections
so
i had taken over that sector and then i
i grew it by girls on the outside so i
got models i got um you know amateur
actresses i got strippers i got artists
i got everything and i vetted them i
asked you how many teachers you said you
had a teacher
yeah one yeah so yeah so and let me ask
you this because i know the answer that
at least i think i do it wasn't that
hard to get these girls for you was it
no because i knew where to look yeah you
know
yeah but i mean they were stunning
i'll bet and you had a roster of how
many would you say
there was about 30 to 35 at any given
time and then you took all those girls
and also
worked them in the the club the
members-only club yes okay so tell me so
i took
i took the money that i had been making
from
um
the alleged um work that i was doing
sure yeah and
and i had been saving it and so i went
and i got an industrial building in
chicago
and had it completely done on the inside
so that there were different rooms
sectioned off and then there would be
like a you did all this big area
yeah i did all this you had a plan
well i had i always had a vision that i
always
always thought that people should be
able to meet at a place
and do whatever kinks that they want to
do
and feel completely safe and not judged
and everybody be a willing participant
not these girls put out on a track you
know [ __ ]
for fifty dollars giving [ __ ] for
twenty when they're you know that's
that's no way to live
so i used my connections that i had with
lawyers and politicians and things like
that
and you know it just slowly started off
it didn't it wasn't like a bang at first
you know it took a while to really take
off it took about you know six months
before it really took off
and how would you advertise just all
underground like yo this is where you go
if you're into this kind of thing and
well first it was backpage back when
that was around yeah i'm sure i'm sure
you i'm sure you know about that they're
still [ __ ] uh like a van that's
parked out here that has a back page ads
like
advertisement on it it just sits in the
same parking space all the time i see it
all the time
is that yours
it's my old one so i sold it i sold it
i couldn't put a bait i couldn't put a
child seat in it
yeah that's rough that's rough
the back page man with a kid's feet
like um so that's how it started out was
that back page at first and then um it
started to be word of mouth
and i had a sugar daddy at the time that
worked and owned like one of the biggest
real estate companies in chicago so he
would take me to like these black tie
events and these charity events
and it was so crazy they had
code words to talk to each other and
open conversations
that they would be able to communicate
about things but if you just heard this
conversation you would you wouldn't
think it was anything give me an example
an example would be like
you know she's an independent investor
and she's looking for a few more
sponsors you know she's got this great
piece of real estate downtown you should
really come take a look at it it's a
loft it's got open spaces you know it's
you know 1200 square feet blah blah blah
like that
so and they'd be able to just slide that
conversation right around like that no
one knows what they're talking about
tell me about tell me about your sugar
daddy what was his deal
well so
i mean he didn't really have a deal to
be honest with you he was just [ __ ]
sugar daddy that worked and gave me
money and liked to lift my feet and that
was about it did you say lick your feet
yeah i love these sugar daddies [ __ ]
these guys always have that kink they
always i have a friend that um
had to have one that um
didn't even want sex he just wanted her
to um abuse him and treat him like
absolute dog [ __ ] and and then when she
was like i can't do this anymore he was
like i'm moving on [ __ ] you don't treat
me you don't treat me bad enough i swear
to god and she would he would come over
and she would he would like kick my ribs
and she would kick his ribs and high
heels and [ __ ] she's like i i can't
anymore like i'm just beating the [ __ ]
out of here the guy was like well [ __ ]
this there [ __ ] you aren't bad enough
to be and he really needed that
and i asked like send him my way
i don't know i'll send him your way and
the whole thing too was
um
i asked her i go what was it why did he
need to be humiliated to to get off and
she said he was in power well the very
he was he was a powerful man but the
first time he had sex
um the girl
it might have been a prostitute pointed
at his dick and laughed at it and then
from then on that humiliation was born
and that's what he needed to [ __ ] get
off like just [ __ ] a woman wasn't
enough you had to like
treat him like [ __ ] he didn't even want
to [ __ ] you he just wanted to be treated
like [ __ ]
yeah the humiliation that's a big thing
with corporate guys and all that stuff
they really like the humiliation
so yeah that's how it started so how do
you meet this guy you just meet him in
the in that world and then he's your
dude and he doesn't want sex he just
wants to lick your feet and give you
money
well he liked to [ __ ] the arches of my
feet so he would put my feet together
and [ __ ] the arches of my feet
that was his thing huh
that was a thing yeah
i was into it i would like read a avon
magazine all the [ __ ] arches of my
feet
flipping through
what do you think of this color from my
nails oh that looks good i paint my
toenails this color for you
oh my god
all right so that's your dude you guys
are rolling around you're starting to
build how many would you say how many
members did you end up um you know
getting members only
so the paying members that were men we
had
50
and how many women did you how many
paying women did you have
we didn't have any paying women the
women got paid okay so it was all that
yep there were never any women it it was
all dudes that signed up for this [ __ ]
yeah we had a couple of times where no
married couples swingers nothing like
that
yeah well we had one one or two times
you know that a guy that was a paying
member would bring in you know one of
his sugar babies or something like that
to ask to have you know to watch them
you know get eaten out or to [ __ ] or
whatever you know or things like that
for group sex but that was very rare
they usually wanted to go in there and
get the weirdest freakiest [ __ ] that
they had in their brain
to just get it out
in a safe space
so when did you get into
being a dominatrix
i got into being a dominatrix when i was
dancing burlesque for a while i danced
for less with a girl that was a
dominatrix and we had a conversation in
the green room and i was like i just
want to [ __ ] on these dudes you know
like [ __ ] them i just want to [ __ ] on
them and
you know i can't stand them i was like
real bitter after a breakup and she's
like
you know you could get paid for that and
you know that that made my ears i listen
it won't make much wait what i get paid
to do that
and so she
had me work at her dungeon for a little
while
and that's when i started to build up a
clientele and
yeah i mean what are you doing
yeah yeah tell me what your jobs are
when you're working there she brings you
in and you're a dominatrix apprentice at
this point so what do you have what do
you do
so the first day that i was there i
i um got a guy for five thousand dollars
she's like this is a big ticket item
like you know we talked about them like
they were cattle
and
so
he wanted to be branded
so i had to get this iron hot
and and [ __ ] brand him on his ass
dude had a wedding ring on i'm like his
wife is gonna see this and be like yeah
why is there a big k branded into your
[ __ ] ass you know but yeah that's
what he wanted that was my first day
there
mainly it was
a lot of this guy
let me just say again this guy i'm we're
going to get to that in a second this
guy gave you 5 dollars
just to brand him
yeah i mean i like pissed in his mouth
too but the main thing that he wanted
was to be branded
[Music]
i love this [ __ ] show
i love this [ __ ] show oh what do you
mean you pissed in his mouth how do you
piss you just lays down you just stand
over him and piss in his mouth
yeah yeah he just he laid down on the
ground and i just squatted over him like
he was a toilet and pissed in his mouth
and told him he was a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] and to drink my piss and he drank
gargle it
yeah i said gargle it before you [ __ ]
drink it you pig and then you did
and then he's like thanks very much i'm
out of here with my sore ass
no he wasn't allowed to say thank you i
didn't want to i you speak when you're
spoken to if i don't ask you a question
you don't [ __ ] say [ __ ] that's how
that was
listen
i um
i remember it was a comedian early on
this girl and i'm not gonna say her name
because she was a friend back in the day
i don't think she's in comedy anymore
but um i remember her telling me we were
at a hollywood improv show
and she's like dude i
my neighbor is a dominatrix and i went
on like a ride-along with her
um like what do you mean she's like well
the guy that she's humiliating
wanted someone to watch
him be humiliated by her and i went
along to view
what she did to this guy
and
i'll never forget this because i
remember thinking like
i've never thought to do that
but this guy
would um she would make this guy lay
naked on his back
and roll his legs over his head
and then she would just demean him just
you piece of [ __ ] like you're saying you
[ __ ] you're a piece of [ __ ] you pig
and make him
jerk off on his own face
oh yeah and i was like
but but as a dude who's tried to jerk
off so many different [ __ ] ways
i never thought that i could i could
roll my legs back over my head if i
stretch for 30 minutes first and bang
one out on my [ __ ] face and i was
like oh my god and he loved it like that
was his [ __ ] thing and then to have
somebody watch him be humiliated like
that
so you've never jerked off and had like
an extra hard orgasm and accidentally
popped yourself in the face with some
nuts i have one time
one okay that's what i thought
but all my extra hard nuts that shoot
don't land on my [ __ ] face because
i'm in control of the angle and i know
better to just tilt it a little left or
right my shoulders have been hit a bunch
you know my pillow's been hit a bunch i
got some in my hair
but i try to keep the money maker clean
you know what i'm saying
all right so pegging dudes too they want
they want you to bang them out
oh yeah oh yeah i had a slew of [ __ ]
all different colors all different
shapes that i would you know i would
just pick out and they would say you
know i don't want anything too big and
that was the key for me to be like oh
we're going big [ __ ] because
you're gonna remember me goddammit
you're never gonna forget the day that i
[ __ ] you
you know you'd be like no bigger than
six inches i'm like okay that means
eight six
yeah but a lot of you know with the like
you said with like the legs up over the
head there was a lot of that with me
holding the legs and then you know
[ __ ] them in the ass and things like
that so i mean that was really common
and they're just loving it
well they loved it they would scream
they would scream out my name
you know
be like yes
and these are a lot of them are married
too
i saw so many wedding rings do you know
how many red wedding rings i would have
guys like
that was just like a key for me that if
they had a wedding ring on that finger
was going to go in their ass
i'm like yeah you're going to [ __ ]
yourself with your wedding ring finger
because i liked it i liked it you know
that that got me going i was like yes
you want to be disrespected we're
disrespecting everybody
oh
[ __ ] all right tell me because we were
talking off camera before you told me
there was some [ __ ] stuff too and that
one always like you said people do have
hard nose like the the girls have hard
nose
yeah so i'll use me for example my hard
no was i'm not going to castrate anybody
and i'm not going to [ __ ] on anybody all
right but it was a lot of that a lot of
that politicians especially i mean there
was a we had a governor in illinois who
went to prison
and he liked to get [ __ ] on in his mouth
wow [ __ ]
the governor of illinois
like the
mouth [ __ ] in
yeah the one that went to prison that is
so [ __ ] v like and who's cleaning
that [ __ ] up there who who's hired to
clean that up
the smells of that yeah that's what i'm
saying like yes i'll tell you what it
smelled like it smelled like a
dog kennel at michael vick's house
that's what it smells like
you're too much
that's what it smells like
[ __ ] in in the mouth in it and oh
god it's it's going to make me [ __ ]
sick
so that and yeah oh god and i'm body
painting with it they would body paint
with their [ __ ] all over them and rub it
all over their face and oh yeah someone
else's we had
yeah we had showers there though
and i had a maid that cleaned so
consuela
poor consuela
oh i she made she made like a thousand
dollars a week for like
a long time she was she was paid really
well all right
um castration we talked a little bit all
right so
you have had grown men
tell you to go ahead and just literally
take their manhood cut my balls out
cut them off off
yeah
so they wanted their balls to be like
cut off and then to be like
the the skin to be like cinched and
burnt so that they wouldn't cauterize it
right yeah that's what i was saying i'm
thinking you're slicing it and pulling
them out and then
i know you say cut off but they don't
really want the whole thing chopped off
they want you to slice it get their
balls out and then cinch their little
[ __ ] whatever's left of the sack back
up
um i i think they wanted them off
because like i told you i had a guy that
had legal papers sent to me
and said look this is a legal binding
agreement that you are not going to be
held legally responsible if anything
happens to me i sent it to my lawyer my
lawyer's on the phone with me and he's
like
we're already fighting a [ __ ] ricoh
case leave people's nut sacks alone
click
would you have done
it was right the blood wouldn't bother
you the blood wouldn't that's another
one blood were you into blood like did
you have a hard no on blood if people
wanted to come in and bleed
so the my hard nose with blood were they
had to have like a blood panel test done
with everything
and i wouldn't cut them enough to where
they would like bleed out but if they
wanted to be like carved yeah i didn't
have a problem doing that the blood
didn't scare someone else's blood didn't
scare you like that no because they
would have to have a full blood panel
done within 24 hours to 72 hours before
they came in so no hepatitis no hiv no
none of that you know what i mean i had
to see it all yeah yeah and i wore
gloves so it wasn't like that big of a
deal
what um
i wanted to ask you about the castration
because i can't get over it so your
lawyer says no or you would have done it
but you had more than one guy asked you
to cut their balls off
yeah i mean it wasn't the most common
thing actually but i've had numerous i
don't know the number but i've had
numerous guys ask you castrate me yeah
and you know i would ask you you're not
no offense you're not a surgeon like
that's not oh no and also you love to
inflict pain i mean you're probably
gonna saw it i don't think you're gonna
numb it and everything yeah pinch it up
on the side yeah i think this shit's
gonna
there was no there was definitely no
numbing
but
um craziest thing of all i mean you've
told us a lot of wild [ __ ] what's the
craziest thing in all the years
you saw would you say you saw go down
there
well the craziest thing that i ever did
i'll tell you that one first the
craziest thing i ever did was i had a
client who worked at the board of trade
in chicago he was like a very very high
up guy
and he would have me he had his own
office and the secretary everything he
would have me come in there
and i would write on his face and
permanent marker [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
owned you know on his throat
he would walk around his office with
that permanent marker on his face
at the board of trade
because nobody could say [ __ ] to him
because he was the boss
he would have like [ __ ] on his [ __ ]
forehead with sharpie and go to work
like that
[ __ ] here [ __ ] here [ __ ] here owned
here
property of lena across his chest
he would go to work because i would go
to his work go into his office
write it on him and then leave and it
was sharpie it was permanent marker and
it was written big it covered these
people are watching a dominatrix come to
their boss's office write this [ __ ] on
his face leave and then he just walks
around the rest of the day working like
that shit's no whatever
yeah cause i would see and i know it
stayed on for a long time because one of
the times that i did it
i saw him
like four or five days later and there
were still like remnants of it and i had
to touch it up
touch it
i did though
all right
that's wild what about the white crazy
[ __ ] you saw
or or one of your girls tell you man
this dude asked me
like what's the wildest [ __ ] because i
know you're hearing wild so for you to
be like this stands out that's the [ __ ]
i'm talking about
um
i think it's probably the guy that
would walk around with a high heel
shoved up his ass on all fours with a
with a with a dog collar around his neck
and all the members
were had like their own like doggy bowls
so people that wanted to could [ __ ] in
one side of the bowls and [ __ ] or piss
on the other side of the bulls but there
were like a dozen of them so he would go
around on all fours with the high heel
up his ass with a dog collar on and eat
the [ __ ] and drink the piss from a whole
bunch of different people
jesus christ
man what happened to that dude in his
childhood what happened you gotta have a
high heel up your [ __ ] to get off i
mean man and that's the other thing are
these people
like i know i'm writing that one down
for
uh
a high heel up the ass um
are these people like
because that's the thing i was talking
to my friend about when she was doing
this [ __ ] to this guy
he never came like that wasn't
it wasn't about getting the orgasm
wasn't what he wanted to feel it was the
shame he wanted to feel so are these
people also coming though i know the
guys you're pegging are [ __ ] probably
shooting it across the goddamn room
especially if you're throwing eight
inches up their ass the way you're
probably batting them but what yeah is
everyone there to get a nut basically or
is it i'm not
not everyone but um
i'd say probably 60 percent were except
for like the guys that wanted to be to
have the sounding done where you put the
metal inside their pee hole no and you
stretch their pee hole no
oh yeah i got a guy to an inch
[ __ ]
screaming on the other side
that's the biggest thing you're
basically saying you gaped his dick hole
yeah with you start with smaller
instruments like like a metal straw type
of thing you know
and then you you get it one of those in
my car and i use it i hate you right now
i'm throwing down i'm throwing that
[ __ ] out when i get in the car
throw that [ __ ] out
i knew a girl i knew a girl that um
would tell me about a dude she dated and
she told me and this chick we used to
write uh at e together back in the day
and she said she would take her pinky
now she had a nice long like a coke nail
and he liked her to stick it in his dick
hole and then carve it around like that
and i'm like i'm crossing my legs right
now
i was like why the [ __ ] would anybody
she's like that was his thing and then a
friend of ours passes away and i haven't
seen the other girl that was with me
when this chick told us this
i can't tell you how many years 10 12
years and we're we're at his like little
get-together in honor of him and
we're drinking and she was always super
cool and she comes over to me she goes
you know what i never forget and i go
one she goes that time that girl told us
i go if you're about to say the finger
she goes i am she goes the way
you got so uncomfortable i was like i
can't even imagine so you sitting here
telling me like
stretching it and then what then what
you put [ __ ] in it you put salt up in
there like what what is the goal of
stretching it
the it's just for the pain and i like i
said the biggest they ever got was a pee
hole to a it was an inch that's huge
that is huge for a pee hole
yeah it's huge yeah i mean there was a
lot of rose buds which is like the anal
prolapse there was a lot of that
happened when you would get you know
your fist in all the way up to your
elbow and then you'd pull out really
quick and then you would punch the
prolapse
and then you would ring around the
prolapse like a donut you'd ring around
it and it would it would kind of bleed
but it would be mixed with lube so it
would be lube and blood
and the smell of that smells like it's
plastic
i'm sorry
are you telling me that you have shoved
your fist you've punched your fist up
men's [ __ ]
oh yeah as hard as i could you wear a
glove like over it right oh yeah
all the way up to my elbow and they lay
there are they on all fours or they on
their backs
both
and you just [ __ ] punch up their like
you get your how deep are you going
elbow
up to my elbow get the [ __ ] out of here
and then you pull it out real hard like
you're starting real hard yeah
and you have and their [ __ ] comes out
well you have to when you pull out you
have to keep your hand open like this
listen i don't have to then you can you
can pull it out
well if you want to do it right now do
it you can't so you're saying like the
fist you can't pull like this you have
to open it back up to get it out is that
what you're saying you have to keep it
you have to keep it in a claw motion
like this
so that it scrapes the side and pulls it
out
it's not an accident that it happens
they want you to pull it over no yeah
they want it yeah
it's called a rose bud
i mean i know
about prolapsed anuses because of tom
segura and oh you know they're touch uh
but i didn't know
i i didn't i just thought that was
something that happened if you over used
it i didn't know you could actually take
somebody's [ __ ] and just pull it out
well what happens is they constrict
around your your arm
so they they tighten up like they're
doing like kegels you know
like you're holding your pee they they
tighten up and
and i'm like okay and then i pull it out
so when they tighten that's what
suctions around your arm and that's when
you pull it out where are you learning
how to do this what's what's training do
you have
to learn how to yank a man's ass
it's just it's on the job training it's
on the job training
you learn as you go
i don't know what pro money to use for
this job
oh my god
all right hold on i have more questions
of course
um
oh god damn okay
um
all right
when you're fisting these guys again is
the goal for them to get a nut or is
that the orgasm for them is that pain
what they're after is this because for
me for me i'm i'll i need
pleasure and pain for me to [ __ ]
like you say come come across the room
whatever that's what gets me pleasure
and pain okay
not one or the other
does that make sense so
yeah so with that it just really depends
on the client that you're talking about
because some when you're when you're
fisting them will also be stroking their
dick you know what i mean so they'll be
getting it you know and you have to
think when you're going in there that
deep you are frictioning you know you're
you're putting friction on the
prosthetic oh wait you're punching it
yeah you're punching it
yeah you're heavy bagging the prostate i
feel like something's going to happen
yeah
yeah
mike tyson that prostate boy
god damn a high heel up an [ __ ] that
one is just something else
all right so here in your um
email
we're gonna wrap up here in a few
minutes but
you retired from the gang in 2019 with
their blessing at the age of 31.
tell me about
you so you're actually out they they do
so is that a myth like you can get out
if you want to get out is that the way
it works or or you always have an
obligation
no so the way that it can work is it
really depends on what you do
um for the gang how long you've been in
it um right before i overdosed i was hit
and dragged by a car
from a rival gang do you want to see
that scar yeah
wha what what happened they they hit you
on purpose like they were gunning for
you god damn it that rip
that ripped your tattoo and everything
clean off mm-hmm [ __ ] so
um
wait what's your tattoo say around your
neck what
what doesn't kill me and is the rest of
it on the back
no i figured you might have finished it
on the back
no
so
um because of that and then of the
overdose and how much work i had put
into the gang how long i had been there
i decided to have a sit down with all
like the chairman and i was like listen
i need to get my life together i've done
everything i can for this gang you know
i've done everything i can for all of
you i have made you all
lots and lots of money and i i just need
i want to get married i want to have
kids i don't want because i've never
been married i don't have any kids
because i was always so scared
that something could happen to them i
don't i said you know
i i want to have a fulfilling life
and they said you know we understand
that and you know they were okay with it
because me leaving
also opened up
them to my connection so they could make
even more money than what they already
were making
because of what what i was doing so
um
they gave me the blessing and they said
you know we're just a phone call away if
you ever need anything
just call us you know we're everywhere
we'll we'll figure it out and i was like
thank you so much like you know i love
you guys but i gotta go and 21 of the
the gang changed after i left i don't
know
why they put the people in the positions
that they took but um
21 of the previous people that i was
allegedly associated with are all under
federal rico charges right now whoa
yeah so obviously they weren't keeping
people in line like they should have
been
and you got out good for you
yeah so now you're just doing hair and
punching dudes [ __ ]
yeah so i'm not doing i'm not drinking
fairy tales can come true
living a dream
i
see um my
submissive clients that are like my vip
clients like the ones that pay a lot of
money the ones that will fly me to where
they want me to go and things like that
so i'm mostly focused on you know doing
hair and makeup for production and
things like that but
you know i still yeah i'm still a
dominatrix but
because it's fun man i don't like it
makes me happy it's exciting i like i'm
a masochist so i like that kind of [ __ ]
you know or i mean i'm a sadist
no judgment here i mean obviously these
guys want it need it and they're getting
off on it nobody's getting hurt
so
i wouldn't say that just humiliated
that's all you get over humiliation
humiliation some people have had to go
to the hospital
have you really sent people to laugh
yeah one guy's rosebud would not go back
in
hold on
hold on
so
you're an ass expert here you know how
to pull it out and you can get it back
in for him too
oh well yeah usually guys that are able
to do that um have done it multiple
times so
it's out usually you can just let me
push it my leg like man like
well usually like i could push it back
in slowly you know and then after a
couple of days it you know because it's
a muscle so if you exercise that muscle
you know it'll it'll go back
but um
one guy i i had a full-on purple sock
around
my dildo you know like his ass came out
and was stuck to my dildo no and i tried
to like roll it off the dildo and it
wouldn't roll off i kept using lube i
kept using lube and he's he told me that
he had put an apple up his ass like a
like a day before and his at the apple
couldn't come out of his ass so the
apple was stuck in his ass and he had a
purple sock
on my dildo so
yeah we had to call ems
no
yeah he had to get surgery
oh my god how humiliating is that
that's how they had to pull in
can you imagine getting an apple pulled
out of your ass and a [ __ ] dildo i
can't imagine getting your fist pulled
out of my ass okay forget the fruit i
mean what's fruit doing up there you
know [ __ ] that
well a banana was too thought
god damn
man you're something else this has been
a hell of an educational episode not
only about gangs but about [ __ ]
dominatrix and about the kinky [ __ ]
powerful men are really into
thank you so much
for uh sharing all these stories you've
been super open i appreciate it my ass
gets to detroit not my ass literally but
when i get to detroit i'm gonna hit you
up here i don't want any [ __ ]
pulling out but uh well i'm moving i'm
moving to nashville in a month so you
can see me in nashville probably see you
down there i'll be going down there to
do some shows for sure good i was gonna
say if you're gonna get married and have
kids and everything get the [ __ ] out of
that area cause you never oh yeah
yeah yeah you don't need to be dropping
your kid off at school and
you're like oh my god that's the guy's
[ __ ] i pulled out last night
that's gonna happen you know in the
drop-off line like hey jacob i know
jacob's dad yeah it'd probably be it'd
probably be my kid's teacher actually
yep
yep
well randy thank you very much for uh
coming on the podcast i really
appreciate it
and uh thank you for having me anytime
that was fantastic um
and all of you out there listen
if you have that story or you know
someone that has that story that has to
be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com you do not
need to be a patreon member i don't care
i just want the great stories this is
your show i host it thank you so much
and again subscribe for a year save on
the money you're getting the honeydew a
day early ad free at no additional cost
thank you all we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
you
[Music]